post css a tool for transforming styles
with javascript plugins when you build a
website the css code you write is rarely
the code that you actually want to ship
to the browser the developer wants to
write code with modern features that
maximize productivity but end users want
fast minified code that supports legacy
browsers post css is a build tool that
makes everybody happy it can take a css
file and convert it to an abstract
syntax tree then provides an api where
plugins written in javascript can
produce a different output for example
by using the auto prefixer plugin you'll
never have to worry about writing vendor
prefixes on your styles ever again or
with the preset enb plugin you can write
modern css while post css will
automatically add the polyfills needed
to support your targeted browsers or you
might drop in a tool like style and to
detect issues before they break your ui
and there are tons of other useful
plugins in the ecosystem to try out and
if none of them meet your needs you can
always build your own you might use the
plugin api to find all the color
declarations in the code then write some
javascript to transform them to a
different format you probably already
use post css without even realizing it
as it generates more npm downloads than
typescript and webpack can bind it's
used under the hood by frameworks like
veed and next js to provide a
streamlined developer experience and
it's also used by some of the world's
most popular websites like wikipedia and
twitter now despite its name it also
handles pre-processing similar to
frameworks like sas less and stylus it
can be used in conjunction with existing
preprocessors or as an alternative to
them altogether if you want to write css
with nesting or mixins there are plugins
that can enable those features in your
code so it's like configuring your own
css preprocessor by including your
favorite features and avoiding the ones
that tend to lead to bad practices on
top of that it tends to produce much
faster build times to get started
install it into your project with npm
then create a post css config file
inside of it customize the array of
plugins that you want to use and finally
run it from the command line as part of
your build process to make your styles
production ready this has been post css
in 100 seconds if you want to see more
short videos like this hit the like
button and subscribe thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one